[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another episode
of San tanco indie movie Guide
I'm Alicia Malone and think of me as
your guide through these smaller movies
that are in theaters and at home this
week let's start with a film that I saw
and loved at Sundance
it's band-aid written by directed by and
starring Zoe lister-jones it's one dish
one dish you're having to be quite the
dish Nazi I might add
when did you everything is like this is
such clean super offensive because I
come from a long line of Holocaust
survivors how could there be a long line
of Holocaust survivors she and Adam
pally played a married couple who can't
stop fighting so they decide to channel
their fights into creating songs this is
a really sweet funny movie that also
tells some truths about relationships I
love that Zoe lister-jones used an
all-female crew and I also like the
chemistry between her and Adam pally and
it's not just about relationships that
also speaks volumes about being creative
it also features Fred Armisen in the
type of quirky strange role that only he
can pull off make sure you check out
band-aid it's in limited theaters this
weekend
at some ranch yeah that's a sweet by Tom
Petty buyer the next movie is also
written by directed by and starring a
great comedic actor it is by Demetri
Martin and it's called Dean a son
dealing with the loss of his mother
Kevin Kline is the father dealing with
the loss of his wife and they both do it
in very different ways the character of
Dean is ricotta soonest he decides to
get out of town and go to Los Angeles
for an interview and then he meets a
lovely woman played by the always
excellent Gillian Jacobs hey there huh
you really ate it back there I saw the
whole thing
thank you I appreciate you coming up to
let me know thank you for yeah that was
me meanwhile Kevin Klein's character is
trying to sell his house trying to move
on and he has a lovely romance with a
real estate agent played by Mary
Steenburgen how do I break the news to
my son he's in LA I don't know what he's
doing maybe he's just trying to figure
himself out the scenes between Mary and
Kevin my favorite walk that line between
being very honest about grief and also
being very funny at the same time that
is hard to do because mitri Martin I
think is such a talent I have several of
his books so I recommend going out to
see Dean it's out in limited theaters
this weekend
[Music]
yeah as you put your cheek against the
window you can see Central Park now to a
very different film a documentary called
letters from Baghdad this one might be a
little bit harder to find because it's
only opening in New York this week but I
want to put this on your radar because
it is fascinating it's narrated by Tilda
Swinton who plays the voice of Gertrude
Bell Gertrude was the most powerful
woman in the British Empire back in her
day she was a spy and archaeologist and
Explorer she taught herself Persian and
then grabbed a camel and rode off into
the sunset in the desert the documentary
combines diary entries letters a lot of
photographs plus dramatized interviews
there's actors who play characters
speaking about Gertrude and at the
center of it all is the voice of Tilda
Swinton who is perfect to play this
female trailblazer that you may not have
heard of not very like a woman you know
do you know what I really want is a wife
to look after my household and my
clothes I quite understand why men out
here marry anyone who turns up lettuce
from Baghdad is an interesting subject
told in a very fascinating way note it
down and make sure you see it when it
comes to your town or when it comes to
video-on-demand don't tell anyone that
to me then you will not come back in the
new that returns
perhaps it will not find out now there's
a couple of films that I want to mention
for you to watch at home this weekend
the first is available on Fandango now
is called raw this was one of my
favorite films that I saw at film
festivals last year if they
coming-of-age cannibal story all told
through the eyes of this girl who goes
off to college she has this self
awakening where she goes from being a
vegetarian to enjoying meat to eating
people but all of that is just a symbol
for the wider story which is about a
woman coming into her own it's about
female relationships and sibling rivalry
it's all in French it's beautifully made
and don't believe people that say it's
too gross out it's too sickening it's
too gory to watch because I'm a big
worst and I found it's fine you can see
roar on Fandango now right now
another film available to watch at home
is the documentary I am Heath Ledger
this is a really sweet tribute to an
artist who has gone way too soon I had
no idea that Heath Ledger filmed a lot
of stuff himself he always had a camera
with him he was documenting his time
when he first moved to LA he was
documenting his friends and he was
creating these all scenarios is all
acting exercises we're going to go on a
mission right now
that's how will you come with me you
will you may have a vision of Heath
Ledger being very intense you know he
threw himself into his roles but overall
what you get from the film is just how
fun-loving and full of life he was the
movie doesn't dwell in his jazz it is
more about his life and it combines
interviews with many of his friends like
Naomi Watts Ben Mendelsohn's
for Brokeback Mountain coma it would
have been unthinkable to have a romantic
tragedy involving two gay cowboys this
is one of the biggest art props on
taking on that character that's an
artist
see I am Heath Ledger is available on
video on demand right now this is like
taking it to the next level like you're
going to be nominated for this I'm
telling you right now you just smiled
lots of great films for you to delve
into this weekend in theaters make sure
you check out the relationship drama
comedy fan babe or the sweet comedy
drama all about grief scenes if you're
in New York make sure you catch letters
from Baghdad at home check out the
cannibal coming-of-age story roar or see
the touching tribute documentary I am
Heath Ledger let me know what you watch
I always love to hear from you you can
find me on Twitter at leisure Malone
I'll see you soon
[Music]